is it clear at this stage whether this
is a coincidence or a side effect of the
vaccine
well at this stage there's no evidence
to suggest a causal link between blood
clotting
and the oxford astrazeneca vaccine and
if we look at the data shared by the
mhra
it says that by the 24th of march 18.1
million doses
of the oxford astrazeneca vaccine had
been administered in the uk
and 30 of these people developed unusual
blood blood clotting so this is
a really rare form of blood clotting and
of those reported blood clots
seven have sadly died but when put into
perspective
this is a really small number enough and
it has to be weighed against
um the threat of catching the
coronavirus and the health implications
that this could have
further down the line but some countries
in europe have restricted
the use of the oxford jab for more of a
precautionary measure
but the mhra chief executive has
stressed that the benefits of taking the
vaccine
actually outweigh the risks and in a
statement this is what they
say they say that the benefits of the
coven 19 vaccine
astrazeneca in preventing covenanting
infection
and its complications continue to
outweigh any risks
and the public should continue to get
their vaccine when
invited to do so now the infection
specialist at imperial college london
has said that looking
at all the information in hands there's
no real reason to be worried about
taking the vaccine
let's take a listen to what he had to
say currently there's no
link to having the vaccine and having
these very rare blood clots
so if you look in the general population
estimates
are between 2 and 16 people per million
may naturally get this type of blood
clot
and so the association with vaccination
may not be
related to the vaccine itself so right
now
there's no reason to be worried about
this vaccine
now there are ongoing investigations
surrounding the blood clotting but
safety really is paramount when it comes
to weighing
the benefits and the risks of taking the
vaccine and that's something that health
regulators
are really focusing on at the moment